the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu Christine Daniloff is the
art director of the MIT homepage she's
the person responsible for getting up
these amazing images of what's going on
on the campus and quite a turnaround
time by the way it's amazing how she
does it we're going to pick up in the
middle of a conversation that I had with
her I value her opinion on so many
things and I also value her friendship
here we go so they send you stuff that
they think would work as an image for
the homepage yes they do though you know
I'm laughing because I already know what
so good they do they often like you know
images from the research you know and
one example I'm thinking about was in
one of the labs at MIT they work on
technology like for photographs imaging
technology and so it was this very cool
thing we're basically if you took a
photo say with your smartphone and it
was blurry and it was just sort of ask
you and all this that the chip that they
were working on actually corrected all
of that all the information had been
gathered in the photo but it would
automatically correct this photo so that
it was you know almost like frame
quality you know you could get this
really great photo so the algorithm
algorithm that corrects for exactly so
when I asked are there any images you
know what they sent me was an image of
the chip thing which you know okay quill
and I think that that's valuable with
the story like here's the ship you know
but so the image that i put together was
you know i started to think okay we're
MIT and
duh I know that the local audience and I
think the broad audience to love some
you know loves here's the chip but you
know the dome and all this but I thought
really what people are going to going to
sort of get from this is that if you
have this image on a cell phone and it's
blurry and it's not really crisp and
then you see this image the same image
and a you know clear crisp framed on the
wall perfect that sort of gets the this
is what it means to like I to tell that
you're telling a story what it means to
my life looks in this and it's sort of
like okay technology but why does this
matter to me well this is why it matters
to you you know and so that's that I
guess is one of the key questions I
always think about answering in the
image is you know why it matters in our
lives it's important work that's being
done but it's sometimes so theoretical
and so out there you don't even
understand that this algorithm will
sometimes make it someday might make it
possible for me to have a robot that
does my laundry you know that people can
get that's what that's what they're
thinking that's actually very
interesting so it's who is the audience
and that is something that we talked
about in the course as well that says it
that says it yeah so let me just ask you
just as some technical things let's say
a researcher does have an image that is
relevant to the science and it is
compelling enough does it have to be a
certain file size for example it does a
high resolution is important because low
res images are small images you know
even though I primarily am designing for
digital display which is sort of low res
already to work the image and high res
and you know just creates a crisper
sharper more beautiful image plus we're
also able to use that image on the new
site and offer it to press where when
press picks up this stuff sometimes it's
print you know it's often you know the
x or financial times or it's a magazine
and they want images and may have to
have high res for print so high res is
always the best way as I keep your
images and large as you can when you
send it out right and you could be at
you as the dark director can zoom in and
absolute you're on framing photography
certain way to miss something is it
doesn't matter if it's jpeg or tiff or
do you care it doesn't I mean you know
jpg high-res JPEGs are just fine I think
so and I guess it depends you know
sometimes in my like my own work or
something you know a tiff is a high res
file hi res JPEGs you know if it's just
a flat image you're not working with
layers or anything like that a high res
J good is just fine so do you have some
examples of some images that you've got
that didn't quite cut it yes I bet they
do we get images i mean i think that
overall my take is that the scientists
and the researchers they really want
great images for their stuff but you
know and I've had discussions with many
of them where we sort of laugh it's like
you know they're the scientists and
we're the image people and you know I
want to make sure that whatever I do for
them is accurate but we've had jokes
sometimes like well you know you stick
to the science and festivities as you
know our hope with the course as I know
you know is to raise the standards of
the researchers work and to get them to
pay more attention to have a create
their photographs if it's photograph
abode of course we're talking about
material that's photographical right
absolutely here is an example these were
images you know it was about carbon
nanotubes that can catch cancer cells so
the images that you know we got were
sort of you know the sem of the
nanotubes and then
you know the proportions of the device
but these are great sort of with the
story like so people I guess have a
greater understanding of the what they
were doing in the lab but for something
that's supposed to grab people's
attention and sort of make them
understand what this will do it doesn't
really it doesn't really work so you
know I basically did just that and I
used photographs that came from like
Centers for Disease Control you know
images that were available and able to
be used but trying to think about you
know how do you get this across and make
it visually compelling you know so that
people want to click in and read about
this so so did you make this nanotube as
an illustration I this yes the nanotube
is actually an illustration of a carbon
nano right you know and it's basically
just carve instructor in a tube deform
you know and sometimes it's an
interpretation of what's going on in
this research you know it's not
promising anything that they're not
working toward but it's we make it clear
that this is like a photo illustration
this is not something that came you know
there was not it's not a documentary and
yeah it's a photo illustration of just
you know what this research is talking
about so there is an issue about scale
here that the nanotubes are much much
smaller than the red blood cells that
were they red blood cells or cancer
cells there it's a the nanotube is
around a cancer cell again then there
are red blood cells because the whole
idea is that these nanotubes I believe
they're catching these cells in the
blood stream yeah okay so the the
relative size of those things in your
illustration is actually not correct and
we've talked about this before about how
far can we go when we make a depiction
of something it but for example many
years you might be too young for this
but they used to show atoms of molecular
configurations and the atoms would show
the reflection of a window to suggest
some sort of three dimensionality yeah
there's no way in the world that an atom
can reflect a window because an atom's
it a little bit smaller than a window
yeah that's what the way they used to
show that is up so you know that so
that's just a depiction but in in a way
there is an issue here of showing that
something that's actually not possible
but you feel that that's really okay
well I think that you need to make sure
that you're clear that this is a photo
illustration or an illustration that
it's not actual imagery from the
research like this wasn't captured in
the body and I guess part of what I
think about is you know I guess when you
say that like well I guess you know I'm
thinking in my head well I guess I could
have made those blood cells sort of huge
where you wouldn't even see the whole
blood cell just sort of an arc of the
red red but the other thing that it
people have to be able to see it on the
homepage so everything has to be a blown
on yeah yeah so they can actually see
what is this showing you know like
sometimes you think if you made
everything it wouldn't read at all
absolutely you can't eat so the
researchers did not raise this issue no
i mean so didn't bother guys at all
clear that it was an illustration okay
and you know that's oftentimes what you
know we're sort of tasked with is
illustrating illustrating something that
you know we're trying to you know show
the components at work here but we don't
have anything in front of us to go
buying is just sort of showing that you
know it's just our interpretation of
what is going to happen when these
carbon nanotubes can capture you know
capture cancer cells but so when I for
example when I color an SEM I always
indicate somewhere that I've colored the
sem do you think that we as journalists
of science whatever we going to call
ourselves today do you think that we
have a responsibility
to indicate for example that that that
you would you have indicated this is not
to scale or something like I do you feel
an obligation I think that a science
illustration absolutely but when I think
about sort of what I do sometimes I
think it's heavier on the illustration
sign I wouldn't tell anyone that this is
part of a scientific document and
there's more of a piece of like I
sometimes think it's sort of like
artwork to go with your story and I
think that we should we do have to be
like not falsely like or give the
suggestion you know knowingly give the
suggestion that this is accurate this
image is an accurate image or a
realistic you know depiction of what's
going on I think that is our
responsibility not to you know falsely
represent these images is something that
they're not but I for a lot of these I
look at them more as sort of you know
art to accompany a story you know and I
say art because you know it's sort of
just like my interpretation of what's
happening good not accurate depictions
it's not a documentary and the other
thing about that I think to do things
accurately as you said I have to crank
these out I think sometimes the research
i would have to do like if someone said
to me can you do a medical illustration
for me or scientific illustration
accurately that's that takes much longer
I think accuracy at that point becomes
critical you know because it's going
this is supposed to be an accurate
representation of exactly what happens
in a person's body when this is
happening or in this chamber when my
experiment is going on that's like a
whole other that's a whole other thing I
think that if I were if I were doing
that I think I need more time than what
I'm sure absolutely yes yeah yeah yeah
no it where it's an ongoing conversation
that we have on campus and how much how
much are we permitted to to editorialize
the depiction in a way right now I I
think like being honest yeah yeah of
course I always try to be honest yeah
what it is and then kind of gives you a
little bit of freedom to you know
editorialize I mean that you know I
think you really depict the science and
a lot of these devices you know and I
sort of in illustrating you know oh yeah
yeah you go right like it was sort of
what they could do or how they might
work yes yes yes I'd love to see another
example of how a nun something was
turning on a key enzyme that blocks
tumor formation and so I asked for an
image and they sent me you know a
rendering of the enzyme and again it's
sort of I know what will work on the
homepage what's going to be compelling
in that format like MIT homepage has you
know sort of elements on it and you have
to work with an image that you know
there's a central image area and there's
navigation areas that sit on top of the
image and so you're sort of working with
images that will allow for all of that
to happen around it but still come
through like the image still sort of
pops from all of this and so you know I
sort of know like looking at a rendering
of an enzyme you know isn't something
that it doesn't yet doesn't grab you on
the homepage it just doesn't ruin you
know it just doesn't so this was about
blocking tumor formation and so for the
homepage it's an image of tumor cells
you know that was absolutely beautiful
you know you just want to look at that
the detail is stunning and that sort of
thing so this is a scanning electron
micrograph that's been colored yes you
know so we use micrographs a lot from
research sometimes they're absolutely
gorgeous they are gorgeous I'm like yeah
yeah if we have them straight from the
research if we color them or add color
to them we always try to state that you
know yeah so people are sort of aware of
what's going on there
yeah and I think on the MIT homepage and
you know covers of these things you know
your cover image has to be visually it
has to really pack a punch yeah so
sometimes the color things like that can
really make a difference I've found and
so when when a decision is made it who
else is involved it is with deciding
whether it gets on the homepage or not
typically what will happen is myself and
the director of news sit down and we go
over the stories which he's read all the
stories he knows what is several things
come into play variety we try to have
stories from across the different
schools at MIT so they're not all
biology or they're not all computers
that's important you try to make we try
to keep a good mix of stories coming out
that are going to be on the homepage if
a story is really like incredible
researcher for some reason very
important oftentimes the big journals
that kind of helps you like well you
know if it's in science or nature or
some of these really big journals then
you know it's a significant story and
and the artwork though those two it's
the artwork and the significance of the
research because if we can't illustrate
it well then or photograph we then we
it's not going to work on the homepage
because that has two on the homepages
you know you know I know it's there's
very little text about the image it has
to really you know there's a short head
and a subhead and an image and if you
can't make that image really grab
people's attention and be something to
look at then it doesn't get on the
homepage it's as simple as it's as
simple as that yes it really is a visual
pay do you have enough lead time let's
say you know an article an important
article is coming out and you also know
that they don't have a visual to go with
it do you have enough lead time to come
up with something I do like I've become
comfortable in the schedule that we have
and
the schedule in our office with the news
director and myself we work well
together I think he understands that I
need time and I will often say you know
sometimes as a visual person sometimes
you just need and some of this stuff is
so like I said theoretical you need to i
will read whatever i have about the
research sometimes it's just the writers
paragraph pitch for the story but and
then I think about it you know you just
sort of like I've got a week to work on
this I know it's not coming up till next
week sometimes it's just a day but yes
big ones you have time yeah it's like I
need I need some time like some hours to
just sort of think about you know you
know like massive entanglement how do
you you know something like that that
you know you don't really have a lot of
visuals to go on this is something that
is it's all mathematical it really is
young and so how do you show this in a
way that's beautiful and accurate and
you know how do you make this an
important enough image to put on the
homepage yeah I think this is something
that we're trying to encourage our
students to think about to not only talk
to your colleagues or the experts in
your field but to think about ways to
communicate to the public right
absolutely and we're not training our
researchers to do that and I think that
that's one of the things that we are
discussing in this course how do you
come up with a compelling image of your
work that is not only very much about
information but it's about wanting to
pay attention to the picture right
that's not it's actually not easy no I
think it's a really particular way of
thinking you know yeah and I always i
think the researchers are great they
always as I said we'll supply images and
they always are excited about sort of
you know some of them very much want to
talk to you about their ideas for this
and some of them they are very excited
about it but some of them you can see
they
scientists they do this incredible work
in the labs and they think about almost
like communicating to their peers and
and the thing is people that can read
like the papers the raw the papers that
are submitted that is you know I often
feel like it's such a small percentage
in a way because some of this stuff you
know I mean I look at it and I just like
wow yeah yeah I got no idea what in the
world what's going on here and I know
these equations are really significant
and I know in the in talking about their
work and improving what you know what
they've sort of discovered here are the
advances they've made that's absolutely
necessary but to someone who has a real
interesting material science but they're
not a material scientist it's going to
be very hard to sort of like break that
down on their own you know so that's
sort of what we try to do I think the
writers in our office are great at that
but the visual really has to and you
know you sometimes grab people that have
no real like I wouldn't say that I'm
particularly interested in material
science but that was so you know such an
interesting image there you go safe
bridges whatever right image that you
know I read that story and Wow somehow
was related to me some way out right and
the image caught my attention yeah no I
think I think it this whole notion of
training the next generation of
researchers to start talking to the
public is not incidental any longer
right and and frankly we have the
obligation to talk to the public and as
you and I talked about all the time it's
through images right that's 12 airy
exciting way to get somebody to at least
ask questions right about your research
so this is not tangential anymore this
is this should be part of the research I
think from the very beginning and you're
doing an amazing job doing this I just
it still blows my mind thinking about
how you can crank out these stunning
stunning home pages is just very
exciting do you have other people that
you work with you do you hire
photographers or
video people sometimes we do i do hire
photographers are mostly what I hire
like to get photographs sometimes of the
researchers sometimes of something
that's got like if there's a compelling
set up in the lab which there are you
know we have or devices you know tiny
devices or something that really you
know what you need a quality photograph
up to better understand we absolutely
hire photographers all the time so there
is a place for photography you know in
this world yeah and what I've also
noticed very recently no maybe for over
the past few months is that you you try
to make moving images some sort of
animation piece to the still am i right
about yes so how do you how do you go
about doing that um like I can think of
a couple for example when I mentioned
the massive entanglement arm that was
totally illustrative but you know as the
researcher explained how the photon
moved through this mass of atoms that
were all entangled and he described sort
of like the trajectory of the photon and
how it actually moved through so i
replicated that in this you know sort of
illustration of what what this sort of
looks like or what it could look like so
he knew that you'd like how the photon
actually went through this and so I had
that to work with and I Illustrated that
and then in animating what I try to do
sometimes I will use you know various
programs to animate and lately my
favorite things sort of is working in
photoshop making gifts in their video
timeline because they show on every
device so people can see them on phones
people absolute them we're like things
like flash you know if you're on an iOS
device you're looking at the still image
that I put into it for you that but it
doesn't or sometimes like someone will
says someone sent me a beautiful
micrograph of a microfluidic device and
sells moved through this device
and so I had this beautiful you know
scan of this device and you know the
channel was very clear like how the cell
moved through this as it you know it in
the research what they were able to do
and so I just animated you know it
basically it was just a small sphere but
representing the cell and this is how
this is how the cells are moving through
this device so you overlay the animation
on the elderly the innovation right on
the image and do you think in terms of
how much time the animation can last I
do and um you try to make it a first I
always thought I think several things
sometimes I've had looping animations on
the homepage and I found that there's a
large it's more of AI think it's more of
a local audience here at MIT but people
leave the home page of all day long
because they will say that could could
there be an option to stop the animation
i have this up all day and it keeps sort
of on been thinking someone is in my
something's happening over here because
i'm catching the movement yeah so I
taken that into account I try to mate
like if you're animating something you
know I sort of feel like if it's a
subtle animation like I remember you
know one I did with a series of
photographs actually for the Collier
Memorial and it was you know I could
have done it various ways in Photoshop
but I did it with a series of images and
smooth fades to make the candle flicker
hi I remember that that was that was and
I let that go up because was so right
you know it was just right it's just
like that just brings that little bit of
life and sort of thoughtful beautiful
too it was beautiful so things like that
and that was all done with photographs
Wow so the length of the animation right
if they're subtle I am more likely to
just let them run
loop them because I don't think that
they're distracting the way that some I
get it you know like if you're shooting
particles through a tube all day long
like I can get how somebody's sitting at
their desks could just be like good
enough so I keep that in mind and try to
make it realistic enough or make it a
good viewing experience first so the
timing is right and you know it's sort
of lending something to the image you
know sometimes it's really showing you
exactly how this device works sometimes
it's just you know like with the photon
how this thing would have moved through
this mass of atoms and so make sure it's
sort of offering something more that a
still image Yeti couldn't yeah and then
and then also sort of like I think about
you know the length of it sort of like I
wanted to start fast enough that
somebody doesn't click right off not
realizing that there's movement that's
going to happen yeah but also give them
just whether it's you know a second or
half a second or two seconds to sort of
you know catch it you know what I mean
before when it starts you know and then
but not have it lasts too long because
that's the other thing you know okay so
it might be interesting for us to hear
if you if you could take us through a
kind of starting point and then where do
you go from there to the next to the
next step and what the final animation
or image becomes can you take us through
an example and I'll go back again to
this entanglement probably because I
just finished this one actually so it's
really Express is everything okay good
so as I mentioned you know big story
coming out about the largest number of
atoms that have ever been entangled at
one time with a single photon so that
was the story and I knew we were going
to spotlight it because it's I believe
it's in science it's coming out in
science it's a major thing you know so
entanglement you know you know guy so I
went over to the right I said this is
sort of what I'm thinking I said I
at entanglement it's you know two
particles you know not join together you
know I'm thinking separated like one on
once i'm thinking the spotlight image
area particles you know representing
atoms on one side particles representing
the other atoms on another side and i
headed first thought about multicolored
you know particles and sort of like blue
will connect with blue and green and all
animates sort of like a ghostly line
that maybe shoots back and forth between
these just showing that they're
connected how does that sound you know
and she said that it wasn't really that
it was like pairs of particles entangled
like that all together but that it was a
large bunch of atoms all tang all
entangled together so it wasn't pairs it
was like maybe you know I mean and to me
it wasn't there wasn't a particular
number i had to represent just a large
group of atoms and they were all
entangled together so those two rows of
just like two separate areas of
particles and my mind came together is
like one big mass great so I started
drawing that you know I put a background
in and I you know I and I do look online
to see like how are other ppl show's
ending entanglement what what exists out
there for this what do people see when
they think entanglement and you know you
go on google images in you ear and it's
all over the map you know so i thought
well you know I think sort of all of
these particles together with some sort
of lines just you know kind of
representing that they are connected
somehow a line that sort of connects
them all together was not a bad way to
go here and so I I have a graphics
person that works with me and I I told
him what I think you know we should do
here and I and so I said if you want to
you know think about that and start
working on something like that so he did
an image and he had sort of like a you
know oscillating wave of a photon come
in and shoot up because that was another
big part of this research is that
they're entangled with
single-photon so you know and you know
he showed me the image and and he had
spoken with the writer and he sent it
off to the researcher and the researcher
came back and said you know I think that
the emphasis should be more on the atoms
like the photon is quite large and
hearing it's really the focus of the
image and so he thought that you know
the atom should really be more the focus
of the image so he talked to me about
this and I said well look let me show
you what I've been working on for this
because it's going to be a spotlight and
I do the homepages almost you know most
of the time I mean probably ninety nine
percent of the time and I said you know
let me show you what I'm thinking for
the home page and you know I showed him
what might you know what I'd drawn so
far and I was thinking of like this line
just sort of like this crazy jumbled
line in the background but go stood out
it's sort of the suggestion of
connection with these particles and so
he asked if he could have you know my
photoshop file to work with and I said
sure you know why don't you work with
his cell let me see what you come up
with so he basically did that you know
took these particles and did the line
and all this and showed it to me and it
was looking good and he sent to the
researcher and the research said he
thought it was probably the best
rendering of like massive entanglement
ever seen which is god okay Evan MIT
reason like whoo yeah exactly but then
you know so I ain't really thought about
animation for this one you know because
an image that just has a lot of spheres
with a ghost in line it's cool looking
but like movement could mean a lot and
so he said do you think you know if and
I and I think at some point animation
was mentioned to the researcher and he
talked about you know showing this
photon come in and then you know go off
at a right angle to like the line that
it came in on is the way that it sort of
moved in this research and so I thought
well great you know that will be the
animation
part about this rather than me kind of
making this ghosted line sort of like a
but i had thought sort of like a bright
thing almost like shoot around in these
lines but to actually trace the path of
the photon tub and so that's what it
ended up being was an animation of you
know i sort of brought some of the atoms
up closer so that there was different
scale and sort of a different focus in
the atoms you know or sort of a focal
point like this Adams will bigger than
nothing blurry in the background and and
then put the photon through the mass of
atoms and any used photoshop i use
photoshop for the entire thing not
illustrator nope not illustrator because
not illustrated okay it like it was a
simple enough illustration where you're
basically just sort of like working with
textures and spheres with gradients and
that it was a photoshop and honestly
photoshop i work in more than
illustrator yeah do so much and yeah my
experience is that when i have to make
an image in order to explain the science
the process of making the image
clarifies the science for me definitely
somebody said to me once when they asked
what i did and i said my illustrate the
MIT homepage they said you must be a
mile wide and an inch deep and it's kind
of it's sort of its yeah you learn yeah
like you know you had to learn sort of
like what the best batteries are being
made of it a little a little bit about
tons of stuff but you do I agree with
you it really does help me to understand
the signs absolutely you know and that's
why we're hopefully encouraging
researchers to think about presenting
your science because their nature of
thinking about the presentation
clarifies what you are trying to
communicate it's a very very important
part of their education and people will
say sometimes I do have people
so I remember that story cuz I remember
there was an image that showed and so I
feel you know that's sort of you know
that you know that gets it across like
people remember a story because of the
image that ran with it and that they'll
remember you know the words but they
remember because that is you know sort
of sparks the memory and that's pretty
cool yeah thank you Christina this is
what this course is all about it's been
just great oh thank you so my gosh what
a joy I'm so lucky to have a pow on
campus who feels the same way as I do
and by the way does pretty unbelievable
work oh thank you thanks for coming
thank you